see if we can get a white game and let's
roll the cameras
es Pedro Sanchez 1490 let's go E4
and great game okay nicely done we won
let's go again
GG very good okay that's gonna be a
YouTube video right there
[Music]
uh more black into 1500 slightly less
appealing pairing but nonetheless okay
Immortal game of the speedrun
okay another Siciliano
and we are right at the threshold where
people start to play more of the open
Sicilian I would say
still a lot of anti-sicilians a lot of
elephants and Knight C3 Bishop C4 yeah
so we Face Bishop C4 again and we have
faced this once before in the speedrun
but we faced it through a slightly
different move order we faced the
bowdler attack Knight F3 Knight C6 and
then Bishop C4 the immediate Bishop C4
does not really change all that much
because well our response is Knight C6
and frequently white plays Knight F of
course white does not have to play
Knight F3 oh I can play Queen H5
um or queen F3 or whatnot and queen H5
is played wow 1500 playing Quinn H5 all
right
well it is worth knowing how to defend
against this move because some people do
get thrown off
by Queen H5 here against the Sicilian is
a little bit more serious than it is
against the uh E4 E5 so how should we
continue well Def and not Knight F6 not
D6 we need to defend both at the same
time and the best way to do that is of
course the move E6 which you which you
should be thinking about anyway the
moment that white plays Bishop C4 and it
would have been possible E6 here is also
perfectly fine it's just that we wanted
to keep flexibility by developing our
Knight first but E6 is a move that you
should automatically associate uh as as
a typical response to Bishop C4 because
it blunts the bishop obviously Bishop
takes C6 we can take with the d-pawn
and on the next move we what we don't
need to do is play G6 you don't need to
specifically chase the queen away you do
want to chase the queen away but you
want to do it while also developing your
minor pieces so without Much Ado here
that the obvious move is just Knight F6
I mean the position I hate this phrase
but the position really plays itself so
far you're just getting your pieces out
and white is already in trouble because
the queen doesn't have any any uh super
good squares the thing is white needs to
keep his E4 Pawn protected
and
the queen has two squares well three
squares technically from which it can do
that it can do that from H4 it can do
that from F3 or from E2
now F3 and E2 both walk into various
Tempo moves with our Knight like Queen
E2 we can play Knight T4 Queen F3 we can
play Knight C4 we can even play Knight
E5 and root out the dark the light
squared Bishop so White's kind of bitten
off more than they can chew here
and
so what about Queen H4 what's wrong with
Queen H4 well we're about to find out
when H4 on the board
again in such
because you have
in such positions meaning against these
types of terrible openings you have a
million ways to play so you shouldn't
get too bogged down here and say well I
have to find only the right move and I'm
going to take five minutes here and try
to figure it out there's usually going
to be two or three moves that are
approximately equivalent in strength all
of which give you a pretty big Advantage
so I think the most straightforward move
to me is Bishop f8 to E7 creating an
x-ray against the queen
now does Bishop E7 actually threaten any
immediate discoveries no but if you
think about the future after Bishop E7
we are likely to play the move D7 D5
right
and if you think that after the trade we
will have the possibility of playing
Knight F6 to E4 and the queen There is
almost trapped on H4 so that's one
option another option
well Knight takes E4 is a move here
but that's definitely not the most that
we could do that kind of allows white to
bail out if you calculate the line 94
Queen E4 D5 the center fork trick white
can play Bishop takes D5 and we can't
take with a pawn because it's pinned
we're gonna have to play Queen takes D5
and I really don't want to allow a queen
trade in this position that really seems
like a bailout
so another option here is is to play
Knight D4 and hit white where it hurts
on the C2 Pawn which is not that easy to
defend by the way so after Knight D4
um I don't see a good move for white I I
really don't
um white might have to play a move like
Bishop back to B3 but then already we
have a move like C4 no we definitely
should play Knight T4 yeah this is this
is very promising and it doesn't it's
not a big commitment to playing it for
so the reason I played this relatively
fast and relatively speaking without
much calculation is just because I don't
see a downside to this move we can
always revert back on the next move to
D5 or to Bishop E7 but we should try to
squeeze the juice out of this position
before whites completed their
development
yeah King D1 I don't think King D1 is
forced I think there are some subtleties
here
I the Grand Master move is actually E5
in this position that is not a move that
most 1500s will think of again when I
say that phrase I never mean it
condescendingly as people understand I
never mean it to suggest that like oh
you can't find that move but it it's off
usually not on the purview of you know
players in that rating range and I'll
explain it after the game King D1 on the
board
so order of operations is pretty
important here I can see two candidate
moves in this position
um the first is Bishop B7 as before and
D5 as before so it's important whenever
you make a move like 94 anytime a piece
leaves a square you have to consider the
pros and cons well the pro is obvious
this Knight is pretty sexy on D4 but
what's the con well the con is that we
have allowed potentially the move E5
right and the movie 5 can be a little
bit annoying because it it clamps down a
little bit on our Center and if white
plays E5 if we think about a bishop E7
E5 we will move our Knight let's say to
D5 and the queen can slide over to E4
and we've sort of let the queen out of
our grasp a little bit so on account of
that line I prefer to start with D5 here
while we still can and after ede we
chase the bishop away and then we play
Bishop E7 this is borderline winning
already for black I just feel like
White's not developed and we keep
hitting him and it's it's just not going
to be pleasant
so hopefully that logic made sense
um again Bishop E7 allows the move E5 is
that is it the end of the world no but
is it much more accurate to start with
D5 absolutely
if white plays E5 here
if y to play 85 here we would have just
taken the bishop
and after Pawn takes Knight we just take
the pawn we're up upon there I mean
that's just a free Pawn
so he takes D5 obviously we take with
the pawn
and we open up the center which is a
nice bonus given that we're ahead in
development I honestly can't believe
we're facing this line this is pretty
crazy
uh but but it we've had a couple of of
games like this where we're almost
winning out of the opening but we have
to handle things very carefully very
precisely
so what's what's hilarious is that apart
from Bishop E7 which I think we're gonna
end up playing there's a funny move that
a lot of people wouldn't consider
because it allows a queen trade but
remember that concrete considerations
always Trump General reasoning so the
general reasoning would seem to suggest
that whenever you have an initiative
quite like this you shouldn't trade
Queens but we can consider the move
Knight to E4
and if you calculate the line Queen
takes queen king takes Queen you have
Knights on e4 and D4 which is a very
powerful Arrangement because they they
make contact with the C2 and F2 pawns
and so white can only defend one of them
at one at a time
it because white can't play King D1 to
E1 because he blunders C2 so after 94
Queen takes the king takes it Knight H3
very importantly also fails two Bishop
takes H3 that's a byproduct of us
playing D5 early the light squared
Bishop has opened up
but there is a butt here and if we play
94 we'll probably win the game really
quickly but I'm trying to play principal
chess so let's calculate this more
carefully Knight E4 Queen takes the king
takes d8
what we need to be careful about in that
scenario is a situation where white
essentially gets two minor pieces for a
rook so in that position white can try
the move C to C3 and I always say this
if you're watching on YouTube and you're
having a hard time visualizing you can
either wait until after the game or you
can set up a board and make the moves as
I say them 94 Queen takes the king takes
to get C3 so what's our move in that
position well obviously Knight takes F2
check
the king slides over to E1 and that's a
critical position in that position
taking the Rook I think would actually
be a mistake
right because then white will take one
of the knights and then the other night
is likely going to be trapped and
eventually won and White's gonna get two
miners for Rook so in that position
what's the correct move there's a very
important resource after C3 without
which we wouldn't go for the line
and blarvo got a knight D3 check so once
again 94 Queen takes D at King takes d8
C3 Knight takes Pawn check King E1
Knight back to D3 with check
forcing the king over to D1 and then the
bishop comes out to G4 and that's
essentially Checkmate white just has to
give up all his pieces to avoid mate
so on the basis of that line
I think we are safe to play Knight to E4
we don't even need Bishop E7 we just
directly go for White's throw and we're
gonna win material here
um and it's a cool line and I'll show it
after the game and of course
Bishop B7 I think is also winning and
maybe even better according to the
engine the engine sometimes doesn't even
go for the material here if that makes
sense the engine just says hey I I'm
going for checkmate I'm I want the
Queens on the board Bishop E7 or 94
looks totally crushing maybe what I
would have played in a classical game
but uh we're fine with an extra rook and
we have an extra Rook here our opponent
also might just resign
which is this has been a really
underwhelming game to be honest I I
sometimes people on YouTube say that I
seem to encounter like very weak
opponents or people who play much worse
than their rating and sometimes I do see
a grain of Truth in that like I haven't
seen a 1500 play like this in a while in
a long time we literally have done
nothing at all
we just brought our pieces out that's a
free rook now
of course there is a possibility that
the Knight is not going to get out there
is a distinct possibility that if white
handles this correctly they're going to
ultimately trap our Knight in the corner
big deal we're gonna give up the night
for a pawn we're gonna be up a full
exchange and upon in an end game that's
still winning but we're not even there
yet we're house we're also threatening
the other Pawn on C2 and white still
can't defend that pawn easily because if
the king slides back to D1 our Knight
moves back to F2
so yeah our opponent just resigns
yeah one thing we know is that our
opponent did not use engine assistance
so I already smelled a rat after Queen
H5
yeah already white is much worse
for for context it's like minus 1.5
already this is the consequence of
bringing your queen out like this and
this is signed now a funny story Hikaru
Nakamura you might remember this some of
the old-timers who are watching this
might remember this Hikaru had a phase
where he played Quinn H5 in a couple of
classical games like actual OTP games he
was about 2600 this was maybe 2005. and
I think he even won one of them he lost
a couple but what's hilarious is he even
played Queen H5 against Andre Volo
Keaton Ukrainian GM in this position
against the Sicilian and here it's a
really terrible move because black can
just go Knight to F6 I think this is
considered best
against E5 it's it's it's playable here
you give up the C Pawn for the e-pawn
and black gets a big initiative Queen E3
D5 and black already has better control
of the center and a nice Knight on e4
this is already an edge for black okay
you can analyze this with an engine if
you'd like it's even worse in this
position because we just go E6 and now
both of the pieces look really stupid
um A3 is another weird move of course
white should desperately start getting
his or her pieces out with Knight F3 I
mean this is just but still I mean we
can go Knight F6 and then D5 and we're
basically just steamrolling white takes
takes this should be five Bishop E7
what's hilarious is Bishop E7 is one
move the engine even likes the check on
E7 to force the king to move and then
just back to d8 and then Bishop E7 and
we've gotten the king essentially
uncastled so there's a million things
that black can do here
um I'll leave you to explore this on
your own let's quickly go through the
game A3 Knight F6 Queen H4 so as I was
mentioning if the queen slides back to
E2 we have the move Knight to D4 and in
order to keep both of these pawns
protected white has to make this awkward
move and then we play D5 and to make
things even worse than that if the
bishop slides back we have Bishop F5
winning on the spot
so I guess white has to go check
and then we would definitely eliminate
that bishop and get our own Bishop out
and I'm not even talking about Queen
takes B7 just look at our development
advantage in this position I mean we're
gonna castle and go rookie eight check
and just murder white in the center
so these things don't even really need
to be analyzed they're pretty
self-evident
uh Queen back to D1 blunder Z4 and
finally Queen back to F3 again allows
Knight D4 this is a transposition after
Queen d3d5 to the line that we were just
looking at no this is just horrendous
and queen H4 Knight T4 is is similarly
bad now a lot of you guys were asking
why not Bishop D3 and I think this is
the best move there is also Bishop to B3
and what's funny is that I thought we
would go C4 but I think C4 is actually
not the best thing that black could do I
think the best thing that black can do
is just to go D5 and continue normally
can anybody tell me a defensive resource
here for white that's kind of cool and I
think it holds on black is winning after
this move I just checked with the engine
but there is the move E5 opening up an
attack on the night not C3 I know some
of you are thinking this but now the
Knight can take the bishop and we win
the other Bishop so it's not C3 it's E5
and if black takes on B3 this might look
very good to you at first but this Pawn
is not that scary and white plays Knight
C3 and perhaps the worst is even behind
him
so
but but here we would go D5 Bishop to D3
I think is the best that white can do
here
but um
here we can do a couple of things I like
the move D5
I was mentioning Bishop E7 during the
game I like to move D5 and the funny
thing here is that white can go E5 and
force the queen trade but again one
takeaway from this game is that just
because you have a development Advantage
doesn't mean that you should
automatically rule out a queen trade and
here white simply loses the E5 Pawn
because if white defends it we have C4
winning on the spot if the bishop moves
uh you drop C2 if you go Knight E2
who can spot Black's next move this is
actually very pretty concept black to
play and win
simple but deadly
simple but deadly
Knight C6 just back yeah the bishop is
strapped the bishop is trapped
Bishop is trapped
funny line you don't need no Bishop C5
is bad because then the Knight takes the
Knight and the bishop has a pathway back
you actually need to move the Knight
away you need to keep the Knight on E2
um and if white plays C3 then of course
you sink your teeth into the B3 screen
we're not talking about this fight loses
all of his pieces so of course white
should not allow this white should play
Knight to E2 immediately to smoke this
Knight out of D4 but we play Knight E5
and before we capture we could even take
the bishop first and ruin the structure
I mean look at this this is just Garbo
total Garbo
so all of these lines are tremendously
one-sided our opponent went King D1 we
go D5
and uh well the rest is is history 94 is
the top move yeah this is best is minus
seven Bishop B7 is a mere minus five and
the reason it's minus five is because
white has the move F3 this is an idea
that you see in the scandi by the way
for black
this this idea of going F3 or C6 in the
scandi if you're familiar with it
black frequently plays C6 and drags the
queen back so just remember this when
the queen is on A5 or H5 there's this
concept of pushing the bishop spawn
forward and dragging the queen all the
way back and here this saves White's
life for now for now because like if you
go Knight g494 the queen can move back
to E1 and whites holding on for dear
life
but Knight E4 is is winning on the spot
and there's just no defense here the
best move according to the engine is
King E1 which tells you everything we
need to know about this position
yeah okay resign time it's over
why can't white just take the Knight
asks can't make money uh well the Knight
is defended the Knight is defended by
the d51
Fisher Sab asks what if 94 Queen before
well now we go Bishop D6 I'm very
curious actually wait no no here
oh you know what we should do here
we should go Queen F6 this is the sex
scene move Queen F6 now we forced the
queen trade
and we just played GF and it's the same
position who cares about this slight
deficiency and structure it's the same
concept Queen F6 is such a nice move
just insisting on the queen trade the
engine even proposes Bishop G4 Jack
typical idea
but this is a little messy I have three
it's a little Lionel Knight F2 check
King E1
oh but you have the second Fork as well
so this is also totally winning
yeah no this is this is the definition
of one-sided and the game is already
over
so pretty underwhelming game but a good
illustration of exactly what happens
when you just shamelessly violate all
opening principles at once you know if
you play sound chess and you don't let
your opponent get away with it the game
will not last long
foreign
[Music]